Here we have a few words,
which relate to different reactions
and whether they are swallowed or released
different types of energy.
The first word is exothermic.
The root of the word is "therm"
which is associated with heat, and that word
means a reaction that releases heat.
It releases heat.
In a situation where we have
constant pressure or change in enthalpy,
these words mean
how much heat is absorbed or released during a reaction.
If we have a negative change in the enthalpy
means that heat is released.
If we look at the enthalpy, such as the heat content,
we have less heat after the reaction than before.
So heat is released.
This means that the change in the enthalpy will be
less than zero. These three lines mean the same thing.
This is true,
when we release heat.
This is the same thing as the release of heat,
when we have constant pressure.
Permanent pressure is reasonable
condition when we do something in a flask,
which is open and has contact with the air or if we look at it
various biological systems.
Now, based on that logic, what do you think it means
endothermic.
One thermic has the same root - "therm"
and the prefix "endo",
it will be a process that absorbs heat.
It absorbs heat.
If we have a constant pressure,
we can say that the enthalpy after the reaction
will be higher than the enthalpy before the reaction.
Delta H will be bigger
from zero.
So, okay.
Now let's take a look at these two words here.
Eczergonic and endergonic.
Excessive, here the root is ergon,
the root may not be so familiar to you,
the term, but maybe you know
the word ergonomic.
For example, "Hey, this is a nice ergonomic bureau."
This means that the desk is good for work.
Or, "This is a nice ergonomic chair."
Ergon comes from the Greek word for work.
So exergonic is a reaction that releases energy to do the job
or at least that implies the word.
Release - I will do it in the same color.
This is something that will
release energy
for work.
And an endogenous, by the same logic,
based on the parts of the word,
it will be something that absorbs energy to work,
or uses energy
for work.
One of the dimensions
or the properties we can use to think about
the energy used to work is Gibbs' free energy,
as well as Gibbs' free energy formula,
when we have constant pressure and temperature.
I'll write it down.
If we talk about constant pressure
and temperature, we have the formula
Free Gibbs or Gibbs
Gibbs definition of free energy.
Gibbs Free Energy Change -
I'll do it in another color.
The change in Gibbs' free energy is equal to
the change in enthalpy
minus, I will use another color.
Minus temperature multiplied
the change in entropy.
If this seems completely unknown to you,
I recommend you watch the video about
Gibbs' free energy.
The reason this (delta G) is related to the energy used to work
is:
delta H means whether we absorb or release heat,
from this we take entropy, which means energy,
which brings a mess into the universe.
What remains is the energy that can be used to work.
This is one way of dealing with the issue.
We see that this formula connects energy to work
with the change in enthalpy here.
So exergy is something that separates
energy to work and we can say that there is less energy to work
following the course of the reaction as compared to previously.
Delta G will be less than zero.
I'll write it down.
Here our delta G will be less than zero.
We have seen such reactions that they release
energy for work
and in Gibbs' free video on video.
These reactions are considered spontaneous.
Spontaneous.
They will run.
And these are the reactions that absorb energy for work.
They will have more energy to work with
in the system after the reaction has occurred than before.
Delta G
will be greater than zero.
We say that these reactions are not spontaneous.
They are not spontaneous.
We ended up with the definitions.
We will now link these dimensions
looking at different examples of
exothermic and exergic,
as well as endothermic and endogenous reactions
and we will understand why they are logical.
The first reaction is exothermic,
delta H is less than zero.
This means that we have less enthalpy after the reaction,
than before, therefore, heat has been released.
Here we see that heat is released.
But where did the energy come from?
In formation
of this new configuration
electrons can go to a lower energy level
and to release energy.
And the heat, if we think about it on a micro level,
is something that raises the temperature,
at least locally. This means transfer
of kinetic energy to these microscopic molecules.
Remember when we talk about heat or temperature,
we think about these macros,
but at micro level,
we are talking about kinetic and potential energies.
What is happening is that
when these electrons move into a new configuration,
they give out energy,
which can be transferred to the individual molecules.
Here we have released energy
and we have increased entropy.
We have more entropy after the reaction,
than before the reaction.
Here we have more objects,
as well as more conditions that can occupy,
also move faster.
If we apply the question
for this case,
this (delta H) will be less than zero.
Here delta S will be greater than zero.
The temperature will be an absolute temperature,
expressed in Kelvin, so it will always be positive.
Therefore, the whole expression will be positive.
We will have something negatively minus something positive,
we will get a negative result.
Our Delta G
will be less than zero, we see the reaction
will be spontaneous
It is logical to proceed,
energy will be emitted, and the electrons will like it.
More disarray will be created.
Another way to think about it is
to imagine the reaction in the other direction.
We will have to deliver energy to these electrons,
to reach a higher energy level and create
these links. We will have to arrange
these four components in the right way.
This seems less likely,
than the reaction we have from left to right.
Now think of something that absorbs heat.
This example is not very intuitive.
The reaction absorbs heat but will be spontaneous.
It will be exono.
It will go.
Delta H is greater than zero,
absorbs heat to flow.
I have these two molecules
with these different components, they will collide,
we say the temperature is high.
If the temperature is low, this reaction may not be spontaneous,
but if the temperature is high enough it will be spontaneous.
Thus, at high temperature,
micro level these particles
will have very high kinetic energy.
They will collide with each other very quickly.
So fast that
will be able to form all these particles.
So the common entropy
has increased.
Even the electrons are in
high power condition to convey this configuration,
had to
to absorb heat.
We call heat, but at a micro level,
we are talking about kinetic energy
of these molecules.
They must have absorbed energy, but where did this energy come from?
It has come from the kinetic energy of the molecules.
At first, they may have had some kinetic energy,
but then part of it is given,
so everyone is stacked
in different new configurations.
If you say, "I do not understand it yet."
Think about what would happen if we try to make the reaction go in the other direction.
We should try to put these four
particles together at the same time,
but even if arranged in the right way,
their electrons can be arranged so as to separate energy.
Also, the temperature is very high.
This is a very, very chaotic system.
The reaction will not go from right to left,
will go from left to right.
When the system is very chaotic, things get hit
one in another very quickly and very likely
the reaction goes in the direction of higher entropy.
This reaction is spontaneous, although it consumes heat.
If we do not drain the heat locally,
the temperature at least about these molecules,
will fall.
But at first, we suppose we have a constant temperature,
so we assume that at a macro level,
this temperature is dissipated and absorbed
out of the system.
Now look at this configuration.
The reaction is exothermic, delta H is less than zero.
We have less enthalpy after the reaction than before.
So the reaction produces heat but is not spontaneous.
It is not spontaneous, because it decreases
entropy in the world.
Reduces entropy in the world
and entropy matters because the temperature in this example is high.
We can look at the equation in a case where entropy does not matter,
when the temperature is low.
Temperature really increases entropy,
but when the temperature is high, entropy begins to prevail.
This expression becomes of great importance.
Here, because entropy is negative,
the reaction will not take place.
If these particles were approaching very slowly,
their electrons could be arranged in the right way,
to reach a lower energy level and
to give energy.
But if they fly one by one very quickly,
will not be able to do so.
If we think of this process upside down,
this reaction is much more likely.
If we have several two-atom molecules,
who walk around, they will collide at great speed
and the components of the two-atomic
molecules will separate.
Or at least on the picture we have something that resembles a two-atom molecule.
Molecules can absorb some of the kinetic energy,
during the reaction to make it from right to left,
but a reaction in this direction is more likely.
From left to right, the reaction is not spontaneous,
because entropy is very significant at this high temperature.
Finally, this example is very intuitive and logical.
Something that needs heat, from heat
and there is a reduction in entropy,
it will definitely not be spontaneous.
Delta H is greater than zero, T x delta S is less than zero,
but when we get them out, that whole
is greater than zero, hence delta G
will be greater than zero.
Delta - I'll write it in green.
This delta G will be greater than zero,
which is logical, because we have these two molecules, which
must be gathered in the right way.
They will need warmth to make the reaction.
to move the electrons to an excited state,
in a higher energy state and to arrive
to this more unstable relationship.
Why do they do it?
This reaction is much more likely to go in the other direction
or if we have several of these molecules,
they will collide,
will achieve a more stable configuration
and there will be more entropy if they are divided into their constituent parts,
than if they were intended.
Thus, delta G is greater than zero.
This is an endogenous and endothermic reaction.
Of course, here too delta G was greater than zero.
Although energy will be attributed to this reaction,
the system is so chaotic that
particles will not be able to connect and is more likely
the reaction proceeds in a direction enhancing entropy.
Therefore, this reaction is also not spontaneous.